欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课。
同学们,第三小节我们来讲一下关于如何写关键词K1、K2、K3更容易获得流量。
我们首先要遵循两个原则,写出更容易获得流量的K1、K2、K3。
第一个原则是什么呢?就是对标题进行补充,也就是K1、K2、K3里面的关键词组合,是对我们整个标题的一个补充。
补充怎么样才算补充呢?比如说标题中有A、B、C、C、D这些关键词,那么我的K1、K2、K3里面的关键词是跟A、B、C、D不一样的,可能是E、F、G这些关键词,但是K1、K2、K3里面一定是包含,都包含有一个非常核心的产品词的,所以说它是对标题的一个补充,
就是能够覆盖更多的关键词,因为你的标题就写了这么,写了A、B、C、D这几个关键词,如果是我在增加这E、F、G这几个关键词的话,那么说明你整个产品的ID、产品的链接就能够覆盖这么多的关键词,比如说你这里是标题覆盖的关键词,那么你K1、K2、K3在外围补充这一次,那么你的整个产品链接,
这些覆盖的关键词就非常大,那么第二个就是,精准匹配产品,也就是你用的词,一定是跟产品精准匹配的,不要去申办一些跟产品关系不大的词,一定是要去选那些关键词,搜索指数里面有的词,同时呢,跟这个你现在所发的这款产品,是非常相关的,这种词去组,组合,K1、K2、K3。
K1、K2、K3。那么这样的K1、K2、K3才能真正的发挥作用。那么接下来我们来讲一下具体的实操方法,第一个就是明确产品的核心词,跟我们之前讲的那个标题是一样的,先明确核心词,第二个就是K1、K2、K3、K里面都要包含这个产品核心词,刚才也讲了,也就是你的K1、K2、K3最后面的这个词,或者是你整个K1、K2、K3里面的
关键词组合,必须包含有产品的核心词,理解吧?产品的核心词,比如说你要发T恤,那么你就是T恤的核心词,如果你是发耳机或者是智能耳机,那么你就是智能耳机的这个核心关键词,必须有,因为你就是在描述这一类产品的,这个就是K1、K2、K3是等于多个关键词指数里面的词组合的,当你在关键词指数里面
收是不是会有很多,很多关键词,很多关键词,K1可能是等于前面这几个关键词合起来,组成了K1,那么K2可能是你后面的这几个词组合起来,形成K2,K3也是一个一样的逻辑,都是组合,多个关键词组合,1到7个,我们之前也讲了,1到7个关键词组合而形成的,也可以是一个关键词,两个关键词组合形成的,
那么第三个呢,就是K1,K2,K3是对标题的补充,刚才我们也讲了,也就是除了部分关键词和标题一样,增加了其他不一样的关键词,增加这些不一样的关键词,其实就是在覆盖更大的流量,有,比如说有这里面的这么多流量,那么你增加了词之后就变成1,
所以说就把这个流量的范围放大了,放大了,这个范围,那么第四个呢,就是选词的时候一定要有关键词搜索指数,也就是你在关键词搜索指数里面,通过词根,搜索出来了大量的关键词,这些关键词你要确保它在关键词指数里面是存在指数的,同时呢,它的点击率是大于等于0的,这些词优先使用。
当然如果是你是冷门行业,那么你的词很多可能是0点击率的,那么这种词也可以用到标题当中,因为你本来的词就很少了,所以0点击率的词也要用上。第五个就是精选同行爆品标题里面的部分精准词,也就是你平时去看爆款标题的时候,那么你是不是会看到它有部分的词,
是比较精准的,或者是你认为比较有价值的,那么这些词你也可以去选一些词,作为你的K1、K2就可以了。最后面我们来讲一些误区,这样有利于我们提前规避,减少不必要的问题。首先第一个就是没有搜索指数的词,就不用,就刚才我们讲这里一样,一定要选择有搜索指数的,不要随意造词,
可以造词,造关键词,就是这些词你不要自己凭感觉去写在标题里面,因为你想的标题跟客户想的用的标题是不一样的,所以你一定要参考这个关键指数去找词,而不是自己随意写。第二个就是K1、K2、K3并不是越长越好,要写满128个字符,一般写满128个字符的很可能就是你去复制的同行的标题。
同行的标题里面会有很多就是无关的词,或者是太多的营销词,这一类词的话会
占用很多字符,同时呢这类词可能本身就没有搜索指数,本身它是没有搜索指数的,那么你可以把这些词
剔除就可以了,所以说不要写满,因为写满只要他不精准到后面推广的时候,K1、K2、K3
也会参与这个搜索匹配的,所以如果是你用的词越多
又不准确
那么你后面推广的时候就会出现很多高曝光
低点击,或者是很多高曝光高点击的词,但是他没有搜盘,为什么呢
因为你很有可能就是你这里面K1、K2、K3写的词
跟这个产品不是很匹配,但是又被客户点了,为什么呢?因为客户收这个词的时候,出现你们的产品在比较
不靠前
那么他没办法,他就
先进来看一下
他也不知道你是不是广告位
所以说
这样写短一点,同时呢,不要用太多无关的词,这样的话你的
呃,直通车的浪费的
资源就会相对来说少一点,所以说一定要记住这个。第三个就是
不要写K1、K2、K3一模一样,也就是
有
关键词有三个框
你不要把三个框写的词都是
一模一样的词
因为这样的话是
相当于就写了一个
比如说你三个写一模一样的,其实你就相当于写了一个关键词,那么的话这样的话你覆盖的流量少,那么剩下两个
流量
就是没有多大的作用了
所以说你这三个
最好是不一样的
不一样的词,同时呢
三个关键词都要填写
比如
这个是K1,你填了K1之后,K2你要填,K3你要去填
这样才能够
更大的覆盖你整个
产品链接的关键词总量
才能
覆盖更多的
流量
那么客户在搜索或者是你在推广的时候,那么你命中流量的概率就会大
所以这个就是我们
如何写K1,K2更容易或者流量的一些方法,按照下面的这些方法去写,那么你的
标题的精准度以及你的推广的精准度就会大大的提升
所以一定要重视
K1,K2,K3的写法
这真的有利于你的流量的覆盖
以及
转化的提升的
好了,这节课我们就先讲到这里,下节课我们继续讲关于标题的写法